Ukraine's president on the world stage
needing to be heard
[Applause]
the crowd in the Lithuanian Capital hang
on his every word
but he has a much tougher audience when
it comes to NATO allies meeting down the
road
[Applause]
today I started my journey with faith in
Solutions with faith in strong partners
with faith in nato in a NATO that
doesn't hesitate that doesn't waste time
and doesn't look over their backs at any
aggressor
[Applause]
is leading his country in a fight for
survival that doesn't just mean
defeating Rutter on the battlefield it
also means
playing on NATO and that requires a
different kind of fight on the first day
of their Summit the Allies reaffirmed a
commitment for NATO to join the club
but even as they met the Ukrainian
president slammed as absurd their
failure to offer a time frame for this
and warned it would play into Russia's
hands the Secretary General tried to
make what ultimately is a bit of a fudge
sound positive we also made clear that
we will issue an invitation for Ukraine
to join NATO when allies agree and
conditions are met
this is a strong package for Ukraine and
a clear path towards its membership in
NATO
but the leader of the Czech Republic
spelled out the risk of empty words it
is in our interest to support Ukraine it
is also vital that we show ukrainians
and themselves that we are outstanding
by their their side because if we don't
uh then they will start losing
motivation
no sign of that for now as a flag from a
Frontline battle is raised in the center
of Vilnius
Ukraine's president needs this support
to mature into meaningful membership of
NATO or else his country's sacrifice
will be in vain Deborah Haynes Sky News
filmius foreign